well the UK has stripped former fighter
Jack lits who has been dumped by the
media as jihadi Jack of his British
citizenship now Canada has criticized
this they say that they're disappointed
in the decision don't forget that this
jackal it's also has Canadian
citizenship and a statement has been
released by the Canadian Ministry of
Public Safety terrorism knows no borders
so countries need to work together to
keep each other safe Canada is
disappointed that the United Kingdom has
taken this unilateral action to offload
their responsibilities
let's dropped out of university after
converting to Islam and moving to Syria
back in 2014 he participated in a number
of battles before being taken hostage by
Kurdish forces in June 2016 he gave an
interview in which he said that his move
to the Middle East was part of a search
for the truth and he denied having ever
been involved in Islamic state it's a
controversial move by the United Kingdom
that whenever it finds that its citizens
are accused of being involved in some
kind of terrorism it moves to strip them
of their citizenship there was another
case recently of Shamima Begum who also
went to live in Syria under Islamic
state now according to international law
no country can strip a person of their
nationality if it leaves them homeless
as it does in the case of Begum lawyers
representing her family have actually
written to the Home Secretary and
accused British authorities are failing
to protect the teenager from being
sucked in and been groomed by Islamic
state the UK has a long tradition of
stripping its Nationals of citizenship
as a means of preventing them from
returning to Britain after they become
accused of being involved in terror
activities European Human Rights judges
have also ruled that this is legal and
what we see at the moment is hundreds
are foreign nationals who joined Islamic
state moved across to Syria and Iraq to
fight in their ranks who are now being
stripped of their nationality
and being prevented from returning home
you